in my childhood I felt happy I painted a
lot and all the grown-ups were
constantly smiling at me everybody was
gentle polite and tender I wrote all
about this in my autobiographical book
isto Istanbul after the publication of
Istanbul some people asked me this
question aren't you a bit young to write
your autobiography I kept my silence
literature about happiness I wanted to
say about preserving your childishness
all your life keeping the child in you
alive now some years later I've received
this great prize this time the same
people began asking another question
aren't you a bit young to get the Nobel
Prize
actually the question I've heard most
often since the news of this prize reach
me is how does it feel to get the Nobel
Prize I say oh it feels good all the
grown-ups are constantly smiling at me
suddenly everybody is again gentle
polite and tender in fact I almost feel
like a prince
I feel like a child